can you spot the problem with this image
this is the baby photo of our universe
it shows the whole universe as it was
when it was just 380,000 years old okay
so that doesn't sound very young for a
baby photo but if you consider the
universe today to be an 80 year old
person then that image is the equivalent
of a baby pic taken at 19 hours after
birth so it truly is a baby photo but
why can't we get a photo from an earlier
time than that well the problem is the
universe before 380,000 years after the
Big Bang was so hot that all the matter
in it all these protons and electrons
was in a state of plasma they were all
flying all over the place and any light
passing through there would get
scattered or absorbed so the the whole
universe was opaque the light couldn't
travel anywhere until 380,000 years when
the universe had expanded and cooled
enough for the protons and the electrons
to get together and form hydrogen atoms
right this clear gas so finally after
bouncing around for 380,000 years like
pinball's these photons could finally
travel out through space and there they
would go on these photons would go for
13.8 billion years the whole lifetime of
our universe these photons were just
traveling through space not hitting
anything until they reached our detector
and that is how we formed this baby
image of our whole universe now of
course over that time our universe
expanded a lot so those photons which
started out as ultraviolet light or
visible radiation blue light ended up as
microwaves by the time it got to us they
expanded along with the universe and
that's why we can't see the earliest
light in the universe but we can detect
it with these microwave telescopes these
microwaves were actually found by
accident to radio astronomers Penzias
and Wilson were actually trying to take
radio images of certain things in the
sky stars and galaxies but they found
there was this annoying background noise
when they tried to make their
measurements so I thought maybe there
wasn't a cable connected correctly or
maybe it was bird
but it turned out it was actually the
signal from the early universe and
everywhere they pointed their telescope
they saw exactly the same signal I mean
the whole early universe was incredibly
uniform according to their observations
so the real early baby photo looks like
this that was the state of the universe
at 380,000 years after the Big Bang it
was uniform so incredibly uniform
everywhere the variations were only
about one part in a hundred thousand so
we built better telescopes and sent them
into space to try to give us the detail
I mean we're interested in in the
variation not just the fact that it's
totally uniform so this is the first
blurry baby photo that we took but we
like that one so much that we build a
better telescope and we got a better
image a higher resolution image now you
can clearly see that the early universe
has these hot spots and cold spots and
and we like that image so much that we
built an even better telescope go to
even better image this is like the
perfect baby photo I mean this is like
seeing the eyelashes right this is so
much detail you can see the little hot
and cold spots and those are so
important to our existence because they
show that the early universe was
actually a bit lumpy there were places
with slightly higher density and places
with slightly lower density and that's
incredibly important because it's the
places of higher density that will
gravitationally pull together the matter
around them clumping into stars and
galaxies and the structures that we are
a part of I mean without a little bit of
non uniformity we could not be here
because stars and galaxies would never
coalesce now where did those lumps come
from well they seem to be the signature
of quantum fluctuations or it's the idea
that we are made of quantum fields and
it's impossible to keep those quantum
fields perfectly still they're always
varying bubbling a little bit you know
particles popping in and out of
existence Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle says that we cannot keep the
uncertainty and energy down to absolute
zero which which means there's always
going to be some matter appearing and
disappearing and that seems to be what
created the
penis in the universe that we can see
and it is that which gave rise to all
these major structures like galaxies so
we should be thankful for this sort of
crazy fluctuation because without it we
could not be here but focusing in on the
lumps we forget that what the true baby
photo is is of incredible uniformity and
that is the problem with this image it's
the fact that the whole universe had
basically the same temperature 380,000
years after the Big Bang and that
doesn't make a lot of sense I mean why
should that part of the sky be exactly
the same temperature is that part of the
sky it's kind of baffling and and
scientists were at a loss with how do we
explain it I mean the expectation after
the Big Bang is that everything would be
in a massive jumble so so this
incredible uniformity had to be
explained somehow so they proposed
something called inflation which is
fairly straightforward but a little bit
crazy it's the idea that right after the
Big Bang we may have had a totally
mottled mess right the Big Bang did not
necessarily give us anything clean or
tidy but right after the Big Bang all of
a sudden the universe just expanded
incredibly rapidly like the likes of
which we have never seen again just all
of a sudden the whole universe got huge
very fast the inflation is proposed to
have started at this time and finished
at this time after the Big Bang I'm not
making this stuff up like honestly it is
nuts but the reason that would make the
universe that we see in that baby photo
is because it would stretch out all of
the wrinkles it would create something
quite uniform I mean imagine you're
looking at a picture of a landscape you
see all these different colors different
structures right it's very varied now
imagine all of a sudden that photo is
expanded in front of you look Zoop now
all you're gonna see is one color
because of how much that whole photo has
been blown out well it's a very similar
thing with the universe we imagined that
we could see something totally uniform
and totally imagine us if right after
the Big Bang the whole universe just
blew up but this is kind of a crazy idea
created to deal with the problem with
that picture
I mean is it really true did an
inflation really have
or is it just a convenient fiction we've
invented to try to explain this baby
photo how could we ever figure out what
happened before that 380,000 year
barrier I mean we're not gonna get any
light from before then but maybe there
is something else that we can detect
gravitational waves now the idea of
gravitational waves is that if you
wiggle a charge you get electromagnetic
radiation because you're varying
electric and magnetic fields similarly
if you wiggle some mass you should get
gravitational waves because of how they
disturb the gravitational field around
them I mean that disturbance should
ripple out through space the problem is
gravitational waves are incredibly weak
so we've been trying to detect them for
a while maybe gravitational waves from
two stars orbiting each other really
fast but so far on earth we have not
been able to detect their existence but
here's the idea if in that moment of
inflation everything expands out so
rapidly then the gravitational waves
from that moment would stretch and
squeeze all of the matter in the early
universe and scientists thought we may
be able to see the impact of those
gravitational waves on the baby photo of
the universe but what we would need to
take is an image so pristine that it not
only records where the hot and cold
spots are it also records the
polarization of the light and the
polarization is basically just the way
that the electric field of the light is
oscillating so it can oscillate back and
forth this way or it can oscillate back
and forth this way the idea is we can
model what gravitational waves should do
they should create a kind of swirl in
the polarization around these hot and
cold spots we know exactly what it
should look like and that is what
scientists have done they measured the
polarization of the light coming away
from the 380,000 years after the Big
Bang all that plasma and what did they
find exactly what they predicted would
happen if inflation did occur and
gravitational waves have affected the
plasma of the early universe that is
what everyone's so excited
essentially we are seeing that what we
thought was true at the very tiny
fraction of a second after the Big Bang
we can see its signature in light that
is only arriving at the earth right now
and what's more we know that quantum
gravity must work in a way because that
is the earliest sign that general
relativity and quantum mechanics are
working together something we haven't
been able to demonstrate before now so
this is one of the hugest discoveries in
science of all time and certainly my
lifetime it is a fun time to be learning
about science and thinking about our
universe because we are just getting new
clues into how our whole universe was
born when you look at all of the
incredible things in the universe the
galaxies stars black holes the earth
people plants computers the internet
just think to yourself in the words of
Carl Sagan these are some of the things
that hydrogen atoms do when given 14
billion years of cosmic evolution and in
fact one of the things they do is create
a website where you can download
information at the click of a button
audible.com is one of the leading
providers of audiobooks with a vast
range of titles over 150,000 and this
week I wanted to recommend a book by
Carl Sagan called contact which I
absolutely love because I feel like he
correctly sort of describes the
experience of what it's like to be a
young scientist I could really relate to
the main character so if you're into
science and you haven't read or listened
to this yet you definitely need to you
can download it for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium or you could pick
any other book of your choosing for a
one-month free trial so I want to thank
audible for supporting me and I want to
thank you for watching